I've already told the
Onigawara I have to give it back. There's no stagnation anyway. Koto
isn't done anyway.
She-sama
Yankees and politicians are
creatures that can't live unless they look good.
It's
not something that prepares and uses supernatural powers toward people.
Normally, there are times like this in Japan and Korea on the back of a passive person.
Tazo Takyan laughs
Tanaka hasn't healed the wounds the other day-Hase
It's tightened to the point where it's completely different.
Somehow, it's my
brother's thing. The
director of the physical remodeling department of cosmology,
Kageyama, Kageyama,
Kore, and Are
Musashi.
It was a land mine
Finesse Ah
, I don't think I've been injured when I was eaten by a glass of rice
in the demon shell.
Ga-amaran Shimamatsuri da Judder
[Applause]
[Music]